time to rev up your engine sema 2021 is
back in town bianca holman takes us
inside the automotive industry show at
the las vegas convention center
more than 50 thousand people are in las
vegas for the biggest automotive event
of the year sema 20-21
the show is back after being virtual
during the pandemic manufacturers from
near and far get to show off the latest
and greatest in automotive parts and
vehicles it's all about innovation
discovery and passion and our industry
is such a passion driven industry that
it's going to be great to have everybody
get together after a two-year hiatus and
start to share some of the things that
really energize them electrification and
self-driving cars those are two big
trends featured at this year's show and
valley businesses will be in fifth gear
as they're expected to see an increase
in traffic with so many people in town
this is not only for the automotive
industry but it's for the city of las
vegas the state of nevada and the trade
show industry itself sema ends friday
november 5th bianca holman live local
now well if you want to attend if you're
a car enthusiast and you want to be part
of the action listen up you can attend
sema ignite friday afternoon tickets are
still available